one of the big things that holds people
back is self-consciousness but
specifically people that worry about how
am I going to look on camera how am I
going to sound on camera what would you
say to somebody who's just trembling
with fear to get on camera because of
those insecurities I say a lot of things
since the core Foundation of my content
the last seven years of my life have
been dedicated on trying to build
people's self-esteem
I sound crazy
not all that I mean I've gotten a little
bit better looking but like you know
like I'm not winning on that like
so
like I don't like high school ended
everybody has zits too
like you know like people are like like
I'd laugh when I was like yo you really
suck at this I'm like you suck too
as if not everybody sucks everybody in
here sucks that's so much it's crazy
right
and but you want to I'll give you a real
answer to what I actually think works
this is a wild answer to this in my
opinion but I've really started to zero
in
I'm going to help you
jump over to hurdle the fear of how I
look how I sound
deploy compassion to those who've done
you
I think the reason I'm winning is when
somebody says you're an idiot you're a
scam you're fully you suck you're ugly
[__] you
my my brain immediately goes to like man
for somebody to take time out of their
day
to come to my profile
to try to tear me down because they're
hurting so much inside I only have love
for them
I'm aware that we're in a societal place
right now where the way we respond to
people's hate is with hate back to them
but I just don't have that gear when I
get [__] on I deploy love through the
form of compassion if you're able to do
that you won't hear them but that's why
I've been pounding on humility the
reason I work is because I've got this
going on
for when I get a thousand comments 860
of them are a goat emoji
the other 140 yard you're a scam artist
when you can't hear either you can move
when you only hear the goat stuff you
become vulnerable to the scam stuff
too many people want that affirmation
and that's why people become unhappy if
your values are based on people giving
you accolades then you become
susceptible to the teardown
I'm just attached to both
can't hear you I'm on the field the [__]
am I going to worry about you cheering
or booing I'm on the field you're eating
popcorn
you're making videos you're putting in
work you're trying to win for yourself
you're worried about Sally pants 97 in
Arkansas who's pissed
if you enjoyed this content and want to
take your YouTube channel to the next
level just click or tap the link on the
screen or go to
tube1kchallenge.com to join our next
live YouTube challenge you'll learn our
best tips and strategies that are
working here at think media and I think
you'll love it